y economía en directo américa de
france24 me acompaña en el estudio
nuevamente anhelaron don daniela vamos a
hablar de las consecuencias económicas
de esta guerra en ucrania que implicaría
entonces para los alemanes annie la
declaratoria de la segunda fase de
emergencia respecto al gas pues raúl
primero recordemos la medida y es que el
gobierno de olaf scholz se vio obligado
a declarar el estado de alerta ante la
disminución del gas procedente de rusia
y los precios bastante elevados
desde finales de marzo estaba en la
etapa 1 de ese plan de emergencia del
que usted habla que es la alerta
temprana eso incluye un control más
estricto de los flujos diarios de gas y
un enfoque también en el llenado de esas
instalaciones de almacenamiento para
poder ahorrar para el futuro ahora lo
que hace es entrar en la fase 2 que es
la fase de alarma y que se activa cuando
el gobierno ve un altísimo riesgo de
escasez de suministro a largo plazo en
teoría lo que permite es que las
empresas de servicios públicos
transmitan los precios altos a las
industrias y a los hogares y por lo
tanto ayuden a reducir esa demanda del
gas natural para el ejecutivo aquí es
clave el ahorro que hagan los
en esta etapa el mercado todavía puede
seguir funcionando sin la necesidad de
la intervención del estado ahora existe
una etapa final que es la de emergencia
que es cuando definitivamente el
suministro no satisface la demanda por
lo que debe activarse la intervención
estatal ante posibles racionamientos en
términos generales primero se reduce el
suministro a la industria mientras que
los hogares y las instituciones críticas
como los hospitales continúan recibiendo
el poco gas que quede disponible y
también reino impuso nuevas sanciones a
russian y si raúl se trata de un nuevo
tramo de castigos comerciales que
incluyen la prohibición de la envío
hacia ese país de una variedad de bienes
tecnológicos relacionados con armas
químicas y biológicas principalmente así
como de mercancías y tecnología marítima
y combustibles para avión también impide
que circulen en libras esterlinas hacia
ese país e incluye nuevas prohibiciones
para proveer servicios de asistencia
técnica y servicios financieros y
también servicios de corretaje
relacionados con importaciones de hierro
y de acero desde rusia y nos vamos a
eeuu porque se agita el debate por el
alto de la gasolina le voy a reducir
reducir le voy a reducir la gasolina
voy a resumir la historia todo empezó
cuando el presidente joe biden jaló las
orejas de las petroleras diciendo que se
estaban llenando los bolsillos a costa
del aumento del precio de los
combustibles que están en precios récord
de 5 dólares por galón el presidente
ejecutivo de chevron que es una de esas
empresas respondió dijo que la culpa
desde el enfoque de la administración
bailén que no incentivo al desarrollo de
esta industria a pesar también de que
una de sus estaciones en los ã ngeles
allá marca 8 dólares por galón el jefe
de estado hizo un llamado al congreso
para que suspenda los impuestos a la
gasolina por tres meses pero fue
recibido con reproches por sus
contrincantes y también con escepticismo
por los analistas
y este es otro ejemplo más del fracaso
de esta administración en un tema que es
fundamental para el pueblo
estadounidense y ese es el precio que
están pagando pagar cinco dólares por un
galón de gasolina que es el promedio
nacional en este momento y si lo que a
la administración por supuesto se le
ocurre es otro truco otra curita saben
que ya está muerto al llegar aquí al
congreso este
mini castex el impuesto a la gasolina
está realmente al margen es pequeño un
poco más de 18 centavos por galón y
recuerden que la gasolina ahora se venía
cinco dólares por galón y la otra cosa a
considerar es que parte de ese recorte
de impuestos probablemente sea capturado
por la gasolinería pero la va a pasar a
sus clientes seguirá siendo raúl en la
crónica de mañana le cuento que surgió
de la reunión de emergencia que citaron
para hoy con los ejecutivos de las
petroleras y funcionarios de bailén para
discutir este tema claro que sí vamos
ahora a hablar de indicadores económicos
los mercados asiáticos cerraron al alza
pese a las advertencias del presidente
de la reserva federal sobre la
posibilidad de ya una recesión las
acciones europeas entretanto no fueron
tan optimistas abrieron a la baja el
jueves después de esas declaraciones
también del dato de peticiones de
subsidios por desempleo en eeuu que
acaba de salir bajaron levemente esta
semana y muestran un mercado laboral
robustecido y también que nos trae para
finalizar este bloque económico y último
bloque económico de nuestra mañana cifra
el día los 580 millones de euros en
pérdidas que estima el sector de la
hostelería por la huelga de trabajadores
ferroviarios de reino unido que entró
hoy en su segundo día nos vamos a
directo hasta parís esta lista de
natalia ruiz con toda la información de
actualidad francesa